why does snoop dogg need an umbrella
that voice dress mom the voice
no the dress no no
beyonce may be a world renowned artist
with more than 20 grammys but her
daughter blue ivy
isn't a fan of her corny mom jokes mom
the voice
no queen bee made a virtual appearance
for the 2020 wearable art gala
which was co-hosted by her mama tina
knowles lawson
and her mom's hubby richard lawson we
got these corny jokes and i'm so excited
about that
like that's gonna be fun within itself
seeing these people
uh tell corny jokes for charity
you know to to not be so serious about
take themselves so seriously
why does snoop dogg need an umbrella
that's a makeup freebie rocking a black
hoodie while she delivers
a little like comedy but her
eight-year-old daughter wasn't feeling
it and
straight up shushed her mom the voice no
blue ivy not impressed and neither was
bee's mom who left
this voice message for her famous
daughter i really appreciate you doing
it joe cause i know how busy you are but
can't you like will you just put on some
makeup and get in some good light and
stuff
cause i look like
i mean it's the gala girl all right call
me back
well beyonce took the hint and returned
to deliver her joke
this time glammed up to the max it's
corny joke time
why does snoop dogg need an umbrella
for drizzle my nizzle
for drizzle
okay so beyonce may not have a future in
comedy but
she wasn't the only one who tried to
bring the laughs
it's corny joke time only for you mom
yep tina's other daughter solange got in
on the fun
how do you throw a space party
well you just plan it
so did megan the stallion why did the
golfer bring
an extra pair of pants because he got a
hole in one
kelly rowland why was six afraid of
seven
i don't know because seven
eight nine and michelle williams
what did one toilet say to the other
you look a little flushed okay i've got
one
what do you call cheese that doesn't
belong to you
nacho cheese get it
anyway e.t caught up with tina ahead of
saturday's gala
and she dished on why this year's
virtual event was so fun for fans
a lot of people haven't gotten the
pleasure of coming to the gala
and they would love to see what goes on
and we got like
everything from behind the scenes
interviews with
you know my family and um all the
beautiful fashions and highlights